we have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime that number is 219 to David
P here is a caller really mad this by
the way oh the San Antonio Troll he's
mad at me
again about things I haven't actually
said about vaccines take a listen to
this hey Pac-Man
I want to talk to you about the vaccines
oh I bet you guys daddy didn't you okay
and I'm telling you uh the other Patrols
in your audience uh to go ahead and get
it and I have a phone to pick with you
about this I think that an issue like uh
moving the country past coronavirus is
something that she easily should be able
to notice unite us but no you want to
divide Us by it by making issues summing
your nose at the other side for not
getting the vaccine No in fact on this
show I've made it clear we need to
figure out ways to just get people to
want to get vaccinated just just
insulting or attacking I don't know what
show this guy's watching but his thing
is he always calls me and argues that
things I've not said were a really
really bad idea to say there's better
ways
yeah and there's better ways to bring
them over uh to the side of vaccines
then mocking them calling them dumb and
calling them unintelligent just so you
could align your pockets and get those
clicks what's this guy talking about not
everything has to be Democrat good
Republican bad no that's true it's just
overwhelmingly Republicans that don't
want to get vaccinated the one factor
that most predicts whether you will or
won't get vaccinated is are you a trump
supporter that that's the number one
slice that we find I mean it's not me
making it that way this issue shouldn't
be political Dear God
is nothing but politicize it you're just
as bad as these morons on the right
saying it's going to turn you into a
pink zombie it's going to alter your DNA
into some mind-controlled
uh robot that is that Biden's you know
me saying we've really got to figure out
a way how to get these people vaccinated
that's the same as saying the vaccine
will change your DNA that's that's a
weird assertion that by the speed at
Biden's fingertips you're just as bad as
these people you saying that the
government should kick down your door
and and I've never said that force
people to hate the vaccine that's
Insanity never said it and telling
people there morons are not taking
there's better ways to do it most people
don't believe the nonsense on the far
right about this all right so anyway
that's the San Antonio troll
um
he will he will Levy blistering
critiques against things I've not
actually said on the show uh we are
going to talk about the Province Town
cluster a lot of misinformation about
the Provincetown covid situation we will
talk about it on today's bonus show we
will talk about why doordash drivers are
on strike
I am boycotting doordash I will tell you
why on today's bonus show
um and we will also talk about the
settlement of the zoom bombing lawsuit
for 85 million dollars all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com